this has been such a long journey to get
Aleta to the big screen what does this
moment feel like and can you talk a
little bit about what that journey was
you know it's been a long time in
development 20 20 years but from the
time Robert and I you know said let's do
this and shook hands on that it's only
been three years it went very fast and
obviously there's a lot of technical
development and so on but it all
happened in a kind of a whirlwind
because he's a shooter he makes things
happen you know built the set on his
back lot down there in Austin where they
where they shot the film and he just
knew what what to do and he's like a
whirlwind so it was great
I was Robert the the perfect person to
kind of take on those reins well I think
for one we've been friends for a long
time and we've been looking for somebody
to do second I knew he had this he's
able to access a childlike sensibility
which I think and you see that you see
that when you when you go at you go into
the film through the eyes of this young
girl she's you know and adolescents
seeing the world for the first time and
he's able to do that he's got children
himself he likes to make kids movies but
he also likes to make the opposite end
of the spectrum very rough hard edge you
know kind of grown-up action film so
elitist kind of right in the middle
it's got its tough moments it's got its
hard-edged action and it's also got this
soft kind of wondrous center to it it's
not just vegetable meant to be seen on
the biggest screen one degree more see
it on the big screen see it in 3d if you
can see it in IMAX see it in Dolby
vision those are the theaters to look
for but if you but if you can't find one
of those see the 3d if you can it's a
spectacular presentation you're also
hard at work on those avatar sequels
yeah couple months ago there was a leak
I'm putting this in quotes because I'm
not sure a possible Avatar titles are
those legit I can neither confirm nor
deny take something back to the present
alright here's what I'll tell you those
titles are amongst titles that were in
consideration and no final decisions
have been made yet for a big a big foot
of thin tape it was authentic it was
dripping with sincerity and accurate I
think you've done interviews before you
pretty it has the added benefit of being
true you are also overseeing the
Terminator reboot I believe can you tell
me about anything about where we're
picking things up with Sarah Connor well
Sarah's back and you know Linda
Hamilton's back so it's the legit
character that you remember just you
know years later and she's back to do
battle that's all I can say about that
thank you so much pleasure to talk to
you
[Music]